in Louisville Kentucky once again today
where a memorial is growing at the scene
of a bank shooting that one on Monday
that left five people dead eight others
injured late yesterday police released
body camera footage of officers
responding to that deadly attack as you
may imagine the footage is disturbing it
shows officers arriving on the scene and
then taking cover as the gunman fired
his assault style weapon at them through
the entrance of the bank this is one of
nearly 150 mass shootings in the U.S so
far this year the one you just saw on
your screen Roxanna saberi joins us now
from Louisville once again Roxanna good
morning to you
Good morning Tony police say the gunman
purchased his weapon legally less than a
week before the shooting at the bank
behind me overnight his family released
a statement condemning what they called
his senseless acts of violence but said
there were never any warning signs he
was capable of committing them
police body cam footage shows the moment
training officers CJ Galloway pulled up
to Old National Bank with rookie
Nicholas Wilt just after 8 40 a.m Monday
to the ringing of gunshots
Galloway stumbled backward as the gunman
opened fire police say Galloway
sustained a minor gunshot wound before
taking cover officer Wilt was shot in
the head he remains hospitalized in
critical condition around four minutes
after arriving on the scene Galloway
shot and killed the gunman I'm just
truly proud of the heroic actions of
those two officers
the 25 year old was a current employee
of the bank they executed a search
warrant on his home but did not reveal
what they recovered there this is
happening in America everywhere
Louisville's mayor a workplace shooting
Survivor himself said 40 people have
already been lost to gun violence in the
city this year they now include the five
victims of this shooting all employees
of Old National Bank Deanna Eckert
Joshua Barrick Thomas Elliott James Tutt
and Juliana farmer what do you want to
be done I want Justice
for my mother I want
them to do something about these guns we
spoke with Farmers children Aaliyah and
Gian Chambers in the bank's parking lot
where Farmer's car is still in its spot
she didn't have to come
but she came from me
that's why I'm so hurt Aaliyah a single
mom told us farmer had recently moved to
Louisville to help her raise her four
children my mom was the sweetest person
loving person a smile that lit up the
room you would never forget her you
would never forget that smell and one
thing I can say about my mama she was
happy she left here happy
I have to step up and continue my
mother's Legacy and that's what I'm
gonna do
Farmers kids told us their mother had
just started her job at the bank only
around two weeks before the shooting
police have not yet released a motive
and in a hard to believe turn of events
Louisville's mayor said the shooter's
rifle could end up back on the streets
under a state law requiring police to
auction off seized Firearms Gail
Roxanna that makes no damn sense and you
hear the backstory of Mrs farmer from
her daughter and it makes this story
even more heartbreaking thank you though
for bringing us up today